um
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
nobody
me
thank you
this
thank you
thank you
i'm maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
yes
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
now
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay
two minutes
okay
[Music]
[Music]
don't throw us off
[Music]
five four three two
one
[Music]
it's not just a little bit
so
so
so
so
okay
majority leader
i ask unanimous consent that the quorum
call be vitiated
without objection
for the rest the hour of 70
at 7 pm heavy arrive the acting sergeant
arms will present the managers
on the part of the house of
representatives
mr president and members of the senate i
announced the presence of the managers
on the part of the house of
representatives to conduct proceedings
on behalf of the house concerning the
impeachment of donald john
trump former president of the united
states
the managers on the part of the house
will be received
and escorted to the well of the senate
sergeant arms will make the proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment
while the house of representatives is
exhibiting to the senate of the united
states
an article of impeachment against donald
john trump
former president of the united states
the managers on the part of the house
will proceed
mr president the managers on the heart
of the house of representatives are here
and present and ready to present the
article of impeachment which has been
preferred by the house of
representatives against donald john
trump
former president of the united states
the house adopted
the following resolution which with the
permission of the senate
i will read house resolution 40
in the house of representatives united
states january 13th
2021 resolved that mr raskin ms degette
mr cicillini
mr castro of texas mr swahwell mr liu ms
plaskett
mr nagoos and ms dean are appointed
managers to conduct the impeachment
trial against donald
donald trump president of the united
states that a message be sent to the
senate
to inform the senate of the appointments
and that the manager is so appointed may
in connection with the preparation
and the conduct of the trial exhibit the
article of impeachment to the senate
and take all other actions necessary
which may include the following
employing legal clerical and other
necessary assistance and incurring
such other expenses as may be necessary
to be paid from amounts available to the
committee on the judiciary under
applicable
expense resolutions or from the
applicable accounts of the house of
representatives
to sending for persons and papers and
filing with the secretary of the senate
on the part of the house of
representatives any pleadings in
conjunction with
or subsequent to the exhibition of the
articles of impeachment that the
managers consider necessary
nancy pelosi speaker of the house of
representatives
with the permission of the senate i will
now read the article of impeachment
house resolution 24 in the house of
representatives united states
january 13 2021 resolved
that donald john trump president
of the united states is impeached for
high crimes and misdemeanors
and that the following article of
impeachment be exhibited to the united
states
senate article of impeachment exhibited
by the house of representatives of the
united states of america
in the name of itself and of the people
of the united states of america
against donald john trump president of
the united states of america
in maintenance and support of its
impeachment against him for high crimes
and misdemeanors
article 1 incitement of insurrection
the constitution provides that the house
of representatives shall have the sole
power of impeachment
the president shall be removed from
office on impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors
further
section 3 of the 14th amendment of the
to the constitution
prohibits any person who has quote
engaged in
insurrection or rebellion against the
united states from holding
any office under the united states
unquote
in his conduct while president of the
united states and in violation of his
constitutional oath faithfully to
execute
the office of the president of the
united states and to the best of his
ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states and in
violation
of his constitutional duty to take care
that the laws
faithfully executed donald john
trump engaged in high crimes and
misdemeanors by inciting
violence against the government of the
united states
in that on january 6 2021
pursuant to the 12th amendment to the
constitution of the united states
the vice president of the united states
the house of representatives
and the senate met at the united states
capitol for a joint session of congress
to count the votes of the electoral
college in the months preceding the
joint session
president trump repeatedly issued false
statements asserting that the
presidential election results
were the product of widespread fraud and
should not be accepted by the american
people
or certified by state or federal
officials
shortly before the joint session
commenced president trump
addressed a crowd at the ellipse in
washington d.c
there he reiterated false claims that we
won this election and we won it
by a landslide he also willfully made
statements that in context encouraged
and foreseeably resulted in lawless
action at the capitol
such as if you don't fight like hell
you're not
going to have a country anymore
thus incited by president trump members
of the crowd he had addressed
in an attempt to among other objectives
interfere
with the joint session solemn
constitutional duty to certify the
results of the 2020 presidential
election
unlawfully breached and vandalized the
capital
injured and killed law enforcement
personnel
menaced members of congress the vice
president
and congressional personnel and engaged
in other violent
deadly destructive and seditious acts
president trump's conduct on january 6
2021
followed his prior efforts to subvert
and obstruct
the certification of the results of the
2020 presidential election
those prior efforts included a phone
call on january 2nd
2021 during which president trump urged
the secretary of state of georgia brad
raffensberger
to quote find enough votes to
overturn the georgia presidential
election results and threaten secretary
raffensberger
if he failed to do so in all this
president trump gravely endangered the
security
of the united states and its
institutions of government
he threatened the integrity of the
democratic system
interfered with the peaceful transition
of power
and imperiled a coequal branch of
government he thereby
betrayed his trust as president to the
manifest
injury of the people of the united
states wherefore
donald john trump by such conduct has
demonstrated that he will remain
a threat to national security democracy
and the constitution
if allowed to remain in office and has
acted in a manner
grossly incompatible with
self-governance in the rule of law
donald john trump thus warrants
impeachment and trial
removal from office and disqualification
to hold and enjoy any office of honor
trust or profit under the united states
nancy pelosi
speaker of the house of representatives
mr president
that completes the exhibition of the
article of impeachment against donald
john trump
president of the united states the
manager's request that the senate take
order for the trial
the managers now request leave to
withdraw
thank you mr raskin and the senate will
duly notify the house of representatives
who is ready to proceed with the trial
we thank you
mr president your majority leader i
suggest the approach
so
uh
good job guys
just takes a little time
i